I had not had sex yet so I wanted to be
in a really fast hardcore down I'm an
angry nerd no girls will talk to me like
I'm unity we're now in distribution
abundance so if you're telling me that
Amazon is agriculture it like seriously
[ __ ] you hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
John fine he's the author of the great
new memoir your band sucks what I saw at
indie rocks failed revolution but can no
longer hear John thanks for talking to
us great to be in there your first band
of note was [ __ ] magnet how did that
name go over at Oberlin College where
you started the band if there's one
thing that will turn you into a frothing
at the mouth
you know tea party absolutely throwing
stones at every liberal Shibboleth you
can get hands-on it's going overland
clearly we're trying to poke the beast
somewhat if we were calling a band [ __ ]
magnet at Oberlin our fliers got
routinely turned down but I want to be
clear about this you're giving us a lot
of credit if you assume a lot of
forethought Brooke went into naming the
band we were sitting around the radio
station we had a flyer there's a blank
space where the name should go I made a
joke the bassist thought it was
hilarious
I mean that was it how did you define
and I realize you're looking back on
this the function of the band you were
in when was what was the point of it
what were you trying to express or kind
of in inhabit by having a band I had not
had sex yet so I wanted to be in a
really fast hardcore band which was a
pretty common male response to that
million I'm an angry nerd no girls will
talk to me like I'm you know like so I
want to be in a hardcore band and you
know that applies a certain kind of
ideologies to it which I wasn't really
into but I did like I did like hardcore
but our grievance was with like the big
mass culture you know like where I was
actively angry at the radio because the
radio used to be a thing right at MTV
and and it wasn't just that radio was a
thing it was like there were five or six
channels if you yeah yeah there were
five or six channels eventually a fine
college radio it gets better but there
were five or six channels you just got
pounded with that stuff journey Bruce
Springsteen you to all the terrible RTL
Speedwagon are young boy whoo boy Wow
yeah I mean REO Speedwagon my freshman
year in high school they'd sold like 10
million copies of a terrible record it
was everywhere yeah and it just pisses
you off so what was the source of the
anger with mass culture because I mean
this is one of the things that reason
talks a lot about I'm certainly
interested in is in the breakup of old
models of mass culture there's still
mass cult out there but what wasn't
being fed by you know the the three or
four major record labels the three or
four TV stations MTV which I guess by
the mid 80s where at least playing black
artists and barely and some heavy metal
like that had yeah by them you know
they're not playing voivod rum but to
your point I just felt that there was a
lot that was not being said I've made
this example before but like Howard
Jones had a song called things will only
get better this really annoying bouncing
super optimistic and I was like you're
actually wrong like things suck and
they're getting worse and how dare it
like I actually got angry about it how
dare you say this to me but you couldn't
find music easily that was talking about
the other stuff you couldn't find it
there was you know beyond the I love you
beyond like you know I've got a giant
Willie and my hair's really tall and
like beyond you know like you know you
were mine or beyond like I'm sad I mean
like there was so much shading I wanted
to get out and it was nowhere so you
take a band like Sonic Youth they went
from you know releasing EPS not being
known by anybody to headlining massive
you know their last show was like a
massive festival in Brazil which
probably had you know like 10 million
people at it or something like that what
does that say about the trajectory of
not just our culture per se but that
kind of means of production of culture
and consumption of culture what has
changed and is that a good thing or a
bad thing the trajectory of Sonic Youth
is really one of a kind you know you
you've got a band that never really sold
a great deal of records in America
probably in the grand scheme of thing
didn't sell them any worldwide but you
know they were known and like everybody
they became part of the cultural
conversation enough that you were a
reasonably with-it person which is to
say like you know any educated
white-collar person in any one of a
million professions like kind of has to
have an opinion about them they're
pretty unique but we were talking about
about you know if we're talking about
the third
five years swath of Sonic Youth's career
from the early 80s until when they broke
up I think two years ago right obviously
you know all of the distributions
scarcity and the channel restrictions
I'm talking about of this music got
blown open obviously now you can find
anything online you know you can go down
to YouTube k hole for like you know you
and I could be like we're gonna spend
the next half hour drinking beer and
listening to Czechoslovakian hardcore
from 1983 to 1985 and it would be
awesome and I will totally do that by
the way you know we are now in you know
to use the kind of trite term like we're
now in distribution abundance and that
makes it very different but I don't
think that really quiet ties into why
Sonic Youth hit it really big or why you
know certain things are happening it
just has to do with that you know
eventually the old stuff was gonna get
blown up mm-hmm
honestly the ubiquity of distribution
it's absolutely in that good for
humanity I mean like I interview as I
get people asking me like but wasn't it
better and I'm like look I miss record
stores I miss book stores but you know
Marc Andreessen the investor had a great
comment in that recent New York article
where he said like I grew up in you know
rural Wisconsin you know I was two and a
half hours from the nearest bookstore
and like this slightly less shitty small
town and like I got there like I'm this
intellectually ravenous kid I got there
finally it took forever to get there I
had to get a card buh buh buh buh
and it was full of like cat toys so if
you're telling me that Amazon is bad for
culture like seriously [ __ ] you yeah I
totally get that but we have now though
is that the ubiquity of distribution
means that like you almost have to be as
much of as insane as we were with music
just to find stuff how how important is
you to hate certain things I mean the
book is called your band sucks I mean
there's a great energy no no I'm just
saying like how important I mean part of
the your music world so you have to be
it it's more motivated by hating other
bands than kind of positively
identifying what you love it's it's -
well first of all it's two sides of a
coin second of all that it was much more
important to me to identify about the
stuff I hated you know
when I was younger right I mean it's a
lot easier to hate when you're like 18
and pissed off than when you're you know
in your forties or your 50s and you've
made various accommodations with adult
life and furthermore unbalanced you're
pretty happy and I think anytime you're
identifying really strongly with a
subculture that's essentially mr dat
minority in America whether it's
honestly like weird underground music or
libertarianism like you know you've got
to know that you know you're gonna be
kind of despised that like your
arguments are broadly not gonna be
understood and that you got to be a
little pugilistic about it and
furthermore you understand yourself not
by just the people around you but by the
people who are not around you're never
doing the things you think are weakened
inept
okay well we'll leave it there we've
been talking with John fine his new
memoir your band sucks what I saw at
indie rocks failed revolution but can no
longer hear is a great read check it out
John thanks so much for talking
absolutely pleasure thanks for having me
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie